- [Narrator] These are pączki.
Or if it's on its own, it's a pączek.
It's a Polish treat made
from deep-frying dough
with a stuffed sugary jam filling.
And then it's covered in
even more sugary icing.
Basically, it's the
definition of delicious.
- Num.
- Oy.
Don't touch.
We need to film it first.
Warsaw's a vibrant city
with a bit of a sweet tooth,
and that's where pączki comes in.
There are a few spots around
the city to get pączki
but no more authentic than here.
This tiny bakery has been
producing pączki since 1925.
- [Narrator] Sylwia's great-grandfather
created the secret family recipe,
which still stays strong to this day.
- [Narrator] And on Fat Thursday,
the last Thursday before Lent,
boy do they sell a few more.
- [Narrator] 8,000 to 10,000?
- [Narrator] Nor can we, Sylwia.
Nor can we.
(gentle instrumental music)